and briggs 401 how likely do you think
it is that shawn watson ends up in new
england after this season remember chris
there were some odds that were published
a week or two ago and they were one of
the offshore sites and we stay away from
naming those because they're technically
illegal and there's legalized gambling
now in the nfl i haven't seen an uh a
legitimate sports book with these odds
but the idea that watson was the
favorite at like plus 300 to be the
patriots quarterback week one of next
season you know on the surface it's like
is this ridiculous yes but
it does feel like he's a little upset
that deandre hopkins is gone and you
just wonder whether he gets to the point
where he's had enough of bill o'brien
and he makes a power play to get out of
houston and uh if he would want to go
anywhere else why wouldn't he want to go
to new england well i mean yeah i hear
that now you listen again we know new
england right now
seems to be all in with jared stidham
and they want to see where that goes uh
desean watson do i think he would fit
the new england way and fit up there yes
and of course he's had a little bit of a
precursor with that with bill o'brien
because he tries to run things that way
as well but i think ultimately
you know again this is where houston
they got to gauge how the season goes
next year a little bit they got to be
aware of what's going on in new england
i would be scared of anybody stealing
desean watson and that we've upset him
to where yes you might have to get
through the halfway through the year
next year and go oh wait new england's
not playing well stidham's not the guy
the future
and i would be scared as hell that they
steal desean watson or anything like
that you know i would think that the
sean watson new contract needs to come
now you don't let a desean watson ever
hit free agency just like patrick
mahomes this is a once in a generation
type talent he is a superstar and you
are going to be in the playoff
conversation for the next 10 years
because this guy can make it happen no
matter who's around them and you just
don't let this guy walk out the door
and look here's the other thing to
realize because people assume that given
the structure of the nfl
if you want to keep a player against his
wishes you can keep that player
indefinitely here's how it works for a
player like desean watson first round
pick you have the fifth year option so
you can at a minimum keep him for five
years you can tag him once
tag him twice at a 20 increase over the
first year tag the third time it's a 44
increase it becomes ridiculously
expensive especially if you use the
exclusive tag like the cowboys did with
dak prescott if a player is determined
to get out of a given city he has to put
in at most seven years before he can
walk if you're not a first round pick
you can get out in six years like kirk
cousins did in washington but if if
desean watson wants out of houston he
can get out and here's the other thing
too you don't even have to put in the
full seven years what if all of a sudden
you say to the team i just don't want to
be here anymore and i'll do the bare
minimum i'll do what's required of me
contractually i'll show up for the
mandatory minicamp i'll show up for
training camp but i'm not doing anything
else i'm not coming to any of the otas
i'm not going to be involved in the off
season program i'm not going to stay
early or show up early and stay late i'm
not going to work on my off day don't
bother calling me up and talking to me
about the game plan i'm just an employee
like everyone else on the team i'm not
going to be a quasi member of management
because i don't want to be here anymore
i don't know how you can be effective as
a modern day nfl team without a
quarterback who isn't all in we haven't
seen that play out yet but but i think
if a team senses that the relationship
is moving in that direction that's the
time to get value for him because one of
these days one of these quarterbacks is
going to say i just work here
i'm i'm not here to do anything more
than what you're paying me to do and i'm
not going to be this member of
management who sets the example for the
rest of my teammates yeah well that's
dangerous you're right and the
organization is not going to go on the
upward trend if the quarterback is that
way so that it's a very real aspect
you're bringing up now if it did come to
that that's when the houston texans need
to go okay that's fine but this can't
get released to the public if we hear
one inkling and pub and the public you
know
the media anything like that
then we hear one inkling that oh you're
not happy here deshaun watson doesn't
really want to play here and now it
hurts our trade value as an organization
but we don't care we'll ruin your career
i mean that's what teams would have to
do in that instance pretty pretty much
because again what happens more times
than not with these type of players when
we know there's a disgruntled player and
he's not going to play it ends up
hurting the organization because they
lose their trade value because everyone
goes well he's not going to play for you
anyways
he's not going to be there so don't you
want to get something for him and then
that other team that's a part of it has
a leg up in the trade conversation so
that's where it gets dicey for the
organizations and
if it does come to that which i don't
expect it to uh
they got to be able to protect
themselves that way too
look at what they did with deandre
hopkins they moved on from him before
the storm arrived before it became
obvious he wanted that 22 million dollar
contractor there abouts and would they
do that to sean watson so and we talked
yesterday about whether or not either
side of the deandre hopkins david
johnson trade may be
hoping that there's a failed physical so
the trade falls apart from houston's
perspective you just wonder if
desean watson has said enough things
behind the scenes that would maybe make
the texans think twice about deandre
hopkins leaving and think twice about
paying de'andre hopkins what he wants
but i don't think it's come to that i
don't think either side wants that deal
to fall apart i don't think either side
is looking for a way to get out of that
deal but deshaun watson seemingly not
happy about deandre hopkins being gone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports